monsieur le président la république
dimanche ce dernier 7 mai 2007 2017 à
l'issue d'une campagne électorale
inédite à plusieurs égards mêmes chants
boul'tout vous avez recueilli 20
millions sept cent quarante 3128 bois au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
soit la majorité absolue des suffrages
en application des articles 6 7 et 58
notre constitution le conseil
constitutionnel mercredi 10 mai vous a
proclamé élu président de la république
le huitième président élu au suffrage
universel sous la vème république est
aujourd'hui en ce dimanche 14 mai en cet
instant précis où vous prenez vos
fonctions
nous vous présentons nos félicitations
les plus sincères sur président de la
république
chateaubriand a écrit dans une formule
qui prend son plein sens pour être
l'homme de son pays il faut être l'homme
de son temps hommes de notre temps
assurément vous l'êtes part au choix par
votre formation par votre parcours et
jusqu'à votre état civil
mais désormais par le choix souverain
notre peuple
vous êtes aussi et d'abord l'homme de
notre pays
chargé de le représenter partout en
métropole et outre-mer en europe et dans
le monde
président de la république française
chef de l'état chef des armées
président d'une république indivisible
laïque démocratique et sociale chargée
de la représenter de la faire progresser
dans l'incarner des valeurs
et la langue et de la rassembler ses
dires
dans ces temps et dans ce monde nouveau
où s'entrechoquent à la fois des
perspectives magnifiques et des risques
certains y compris pour notre planète
l'importance essentielle est la
difficulté de votre mission conduite
avec le gouvernement lui même contrôlé
par le parlement apaiser les colères
réparer les blessures lever les doutes
tracer la route et incarner les espoirs
voilà pourquoi monsieur le président de
la république votre réussite sera la
réussite de la france et voilà pourquoi
nous vous présentons pour votre mandat
pour vos proches et pour vous même nos
voeux extrêmement chaleureux de succès